all right ready
280 for the pork 350 for the buttered
noodles 150 foot roll and 75 for butter
it's like you have calorie Asperger's
that's not breakfast with me there is
coffee you do a lot of sit-ups I'm not
going to treat you if you aren't
interested in living good speech
important under control isn't it funny
he's a cage Laden under control
[Music]
you okay honey I just got up too fast so
welcome to our new house member Ellen
hey
oh well how do you do it eat I mean I'm
not gonna lie I'm really [ __ ] hungry
[Music]
huh like a ghost I feel kind of angry
it's my life too I don't get to have a
sister
what's going on with you I just don't
see why people say they love you
but what they mean is they love how
loving you makes them feel about
themselves to even know where to start
with that there's all kinds of wrong
way that you're going one day you won't
wake up I can't stop every time you hear
that voice I want you to tell it to [ __ ]
off [ __ ] off boys
somebody tell me why are you as we're
alive
very good
[Music]
some of them actually seem like they're
doing okay like they might get lives and
be sigh interesting people
did you just say something optimistic I
did say semi
[Music]
[Music]